it could be having much more impact it's
absolutely urgent that we and everybody
else have much more impact the
collective impact we've all been having
for the last 20 years has obviously been
insufficient so the very short answer is
it is absolutely essential that we all
figure out how to be more effective more
results driven better listening and
learning because when the world changes
quickly that's the big risk the big risk
is that you keep acting on things you
think you know and maybe you once did
nothing but they're no longer true and
you keep acting on the basis of that old
information because you're not listening
or you're not working so absolutely
we've got a huge as I said I'm starting
all over again I'm starting all over
again what have we contributed my
organization is 117 years old we have a
hundred and seventeen years of
experience at stopping bad things from
happening and we are actually very good
at that we have relatively literally
when we set our eyes on something and
said we really don't want that to happen
it almost never happened and people who
wanted to happen almost invariably
thought we were destroying them one of
the first battles I was involved in was
the Boeing aircraft corporation was
trying to build an SST and the suspect
in the 1970s supersonic transport like
the Concorde huge government huge
taxpayer subsidies we thought it was a
terrible idea to have lots of sonic
booms all over the United States we
fought it we stopped it we saved the
boeing company from bankruptcy now
boeing is building a dreamliner which is
going to save twenty five percent of the
fossil fuel that we use to fly from here
to London so it's a very different
Boeing Company and we got to be very
good at stopping the SST there aren't
250 nuclear power plants in this country
that's because of organizations like the
Sierra Club so we got very good at
stopping bad things
what we didn't get so good at with
speeding up good things there aren't
enough solar cells there aren't enough
wind turbines there aren't enough
organic farms there's a whole bunch of
good stuff that we didn't really figure
out how to take the scale how to make
happen quickly and that's the challenge
for this century how do we make the good
stuff happen how do we take the place in
the world's economy of the old bad stuff